Stephen King
the pop novelist
he just tweeted out he said hey kids
it's your old buddy Steve King here
telling you that if they ban a book in
your school haul your ass to the nearest
bookstore or Library ASAP
and find out what they don't want you to
read
but they who are they I don't know is
they
Ron DeSantis
who's that he sounds like Kanye over
here who who's they though who is they
well it depends who they is I guess
because I know this is a very popular
opinion
is the opinion don't ban any books if
there's a Banned Book we need to go read
it immediately
well it depends what the book is and it
depends who does the Banning if the
Banning is being done by bad people
who who are not going to help you become
educated then I guess you should go read
the book If the book is being banned by
just and wise and prudent authorities
then maybe don't read the book